with the
pfl how did you get involved in that
because for people
there's like they just did an espn deal
my uh my producers just did a
yeah that's a big deal man super big um
yeah so it's been going on for about two
three years now uh
so you're you're a part owner of pfl
yeah yep
um and basically it's just alternative
to the other fighting leagues
and um we have a regular season and we
have playoffs and we have a championship
and other superstars who competed other
places they can come to the pfl
and join the season and we go off of a
point system
so the people with the most points
that's who advances in their weight
class
is it similar to like i think a point
system i think like the way nascar does
it is it kind of close to that i don't
know [ __ ] about nascar
i just know that they do i just know
they do points
i mean i could learn about nascar so
instead so essentially
because that's a new way of doing it
because you're talking about season you
know we're so used to seeing ufc it's a
pay-per-view thing it's like
so this is like more like like may the
best person win
whoever's got the end of the points goes
to the play is it like play-offs yeah
it's playoffs for show and then
championship fire
um you know clarissa schills yeah female
boxers she crossed over to the pfl so
she's making her mma
debut with us over there
so it's gonna be a lot of stuff like
that where you see maybe people from
other sports crossover or people who are
superstars in other uh other leagues
they might not have you know got their
championships right
but they come to the pfl would um would
you guys take on
like celebrity fights yeah like if one
of these paul bros were like hey man i'm
trying to get in the octagon see why not
i don't see why not we would train them
up we would
start them in the season and we see how
far they go yeah
i mean you got to compete like it's not
going to be like a popularity contest
so yeah i think that that's what those
dudes they bang like they really fight
that's what i've been trying to i mean
like look man like i'm a you know if
you're a boxing fan you gotta at least
be excited that um
there's attention on the sport again
right because on the because on the
undercards of these fights there's some
real boxing music
i mean like the actual fights that we've
seen so far haven't been like
real fights they've been more like
exhibitions or right right
you know what i'm saying it's like you
know we get in there but
the way that they train and what they're
prepared for they really
they're really fighting you know i mean
they're not just taking pictures or
going to the gym and [ __ ]
warming up and looking good like they're
getting it in yeah
i think that uh that'd be crazy so
what what do you think would
differentiate the pfl
from because you know there's bellator
there's there's ufc
i would say those are probably the big
two right right but you guys got an espn
deal which is all
automatically great because you you know
you got eyes behind it but
what what kind of differentiates what
you guys do or or makes what you guys do
unique compared to
those two um it's more for the fighters
and for the fans
um not to say that take away from any
other
corporation but uh yeah we just keep
both in mind we want the fighters to
make money
as well as gain popularity and we want
the fans to get the best
uh bang for their buck so you know you
have your lower tier
you could start here and then you got
your uh
you mean gets a little bit higher and
then you got your top tier so
you you getting what you spend your
money on and what you spend your time
paying attention i do feel like that's
one thing we always hear about ufc is
that the fighters kind of get
paid yeah the fight is fairly the
fighters
have issues they have gripes yeah yeah
yeah because you'll see some of these
pay-per-view numbers and then you'll
hear what someone made who fought and
you'd be like
yeah there's this what's happening i
forget what the exact numbers are but
there's
only a handful of um you know those
fighters who have actually fought for
a million dollars or more and that's
what our main prize is is at the end of
it you get a million dollars if you win
and a championship
oh yeah i mean yeah that's that's a
that's awesome [ __ ] you it's a
no-brainer
um trey hard win a mill